FILIBUSTER IN THE SENATE.
DOUG McKELWAY TELLS US TONIGHT
IT'S A ROAD WE AS A COUNTRY HAVE
BEEN DONE BEFORE.
>> TONIGHT I ASK YOU TO GIVE ME
WHAT 43 GOVERNORS ALREADY HAVE
GIVEN ME, A LINE ITEM VETO.
>> GENERATIONS OF PRESIDENTS
WANTED A LINE ITEM VETO.
NONE HAD IT UNTIL THE CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION WHEN CONGRESS
PASSED THE LINE ITEM VETO ACT OF
1996.
CLINTON USED IT 82 TIMES BEFORE
THE SUPREME COURT RULED IT
UNCONSTITUTIONAL TWO YEARS
LATER.
THAT DIDN'T STOP FUTURE
PRESIDENTS FROM WANTING IT.
>> I THINK THERE IS NOT A
PRESIDENT OUT THERE WHO WOULDN'T
LOVE TO HAVE IT.
>> INCLUDING PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO
IS FRUSTRATED AT THE DEMOCRATIC
LEVERAGE IN THE SPENDING BILL.
IT GAVE TAXPAYERS MORE DEFICIT
SPENDING.
>> I'M CALLING ON CONGRESS TO
GIVE ME A LINE ITEM VETO FOR ALL
GOVERNMENT SPENDING BILLS.
>> TREASURY SECRETARY STATEMENT
AGAIN REPEATED THE PRESIDENT'S
CALL ON SUNDAY, PAYING NO HEED
TO ITS UNCONSTITUTIONALITY.
>> I THINK THEY SHOULD GIVE THE
PRESIDENT A LINE ITEM VETO.
>> RULED UNCONSTITUTIONAL BY B
>> RULED UNCONSTITUTIONAL BY Y
>> RULED UNCONSTITUTIONAL BY T
>> RULED UNCONSTITUTIONAL BY E
SUPREME COURT'S.
>> CONGRESS CAN PASS A RULE THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO DO IT.
>> IT WOULD TAKE A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT.
CONGRESS TRIED IN 2011 AFTER THE
HIGH COURT RULING.
IT TINKERED WITH A MORE MODERN
VERSION OF A LINE ITEM VETO THAT
ATTEMPTED TO MAINTAIN THE
BALANCE OF POWER.
>> THE PRESIDENT WOULD PROPOSE
CUTS AND CONGRESS WOULD HAVE TO
APPROVE THOSE CUTS.
THE PRESIDENT COULDN'T GO IN AND
STRIKE EVERYTHING HE WANTED.
>> THAT BILL DIED IN THE SENATE.
WHERE DOES IT LEAVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> HE WANTS TO FIX THE BUDGET
PROCESS.
HIS MESSAGE TO LEADERS IN
CONGRESS IN BOTH PARTIES IS THAT
IF SOMETHING SIMILAR HAPPENS
AGAIN, IS MUCH MORE INCLINED TO
VETO IT.
>> LOOK OUT FOR SEPTEMBER 30,
THE DATE THE CURRENT FUNDING
BILL RUNS OUT IN THE PROCESS